blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman let's get right into things today
because we have so much to discuss i'm
not going to waste 10 minutes with a
meta segment telling you what's going to
be on today's show i mean this is the
show let's just do the show right that's
my perspective uh i told you yesterday
that today we would talk about
a sort of new it's almost like an
anti-consensus the increasingly the
consensus from scientists about
covid and the trajectory of this
pandemic is
the end is uncertain we don't actually
know and you'll still hear
some individual public health experts
and epidemiologists and others say
if we do x we'll probably be mostly back
to normal by some date
but at this point it should be pretty
clear to most of us that
it's not clear when this is going to end
and that the ifs that are often referred
to if we get to this level of
vaccination
if there is no more contagious or
dangerous variant if this these are ifs
over which
we really have very little information
and it's a significantly unclear so i
want to start here
um with an article that outlines this
for scientists path to covet end game
remains uncertain this is for by mark
fisher from the washington post from
this weekend
it's basically over already it will end
this october or maybe it won't be over
till next spring or late next year or
two or three years down the road
from the most respected epidemiologists
to public health experts who have
navigated past disease panics from
polemicists to political partisans
or partisans as some like to say there
are no definitive answers to the central
question in american life as a drudge
report headline put it recently is it
ever going to end with children
returning to classrooms in many cases
for the first time in 18 months and as
the highly contagious delta variant and
spotty vaccination uptake send case
numbers and death shooting upward many
americans wonder what exactly has to
happen before life can return to
something that looks and feels like
2019.
the article rightly pointing out the
answers come in a kaleidoscopic
cavalcade of scenarios some suggested
with utmost humility others with
mathematical confidence the pandemic
will end because deaths finally drop to
about the same level we're accustomed to
seeing from the flu each year or it will
end when most kids are vaccinated or it
will end because americans are finally
exhausted by all the restrictions on
daily life
innumerable predictions over the course
of the pandemic have come up lame some
scientists have sworn off sooth saying
but as they learn more about the
coronavirus that bestowed or bestowed
covet 19 on mankind they build models
and make projections and describe the
hurdles that remain before people can
pull their masks pull off the masks and
go about their lives the good news is
there is some fuel from for optimism and
i think that
i think that this is accurate in terms
of the possibilities of optimism let's
look at what it says
i truly truly think we are in the
endgame says monica gandhi
an infectious disease specialist the
cases will start plummeting in mid to
late september and by mid-october we
will be in a manageable place where the
virus is a concern for health
professionals but not really for the
general public that is very optimistic
but we are seeing
if you expect cases to be much lower in
october the leveling off we've seen over
the last seven days
suggests that that's a possibility
gandhi bases our optimism on the fact
that all previous epidemics of
respiratory viruses have ended through
the acquisition of immunity whether
vaccination or natural infection
although viruses do keep changing
potentially circumventing people's
defenses they mutate quickly at a cost
to themselves weakening over time
our guest
vincent racaniello last week from the
this week in virology podcast said the
same
in terms of the mutating to be less uh
serious gandhi said she believes the
delta variant that has hit the u.s so
hard this summer will mark the peak of
the viruses strength but
gandhi warns she has been wrong before
in february 20 she said the u.s would
not tolerate a disease that killed 100
americans a day people would come
together and do whatever it takes to
stop that that didn't happen the bad
news is there is too much cause for
doubt
zeke emmanuel professor of medical
ethics at upenn we're in a moment of
uncertainty and humans don't do well
with uncertainty telling people it's
going to be two or three more years of
this is really hard but i don't think
anyone can be comfortable with the
current state with a lot of kids ending
up in the hospital and a thousand deaths
a day
that's not returning to normal and
emanuel also says his crystal ball has
sometimes been cloudy in march of 20 he
said the country would be back to normal
in november of 21.
for that his friends dubbed him mr
pessimist now his message is at least as
unwelcome it's going to be at least
spring 22 and possibly much longer
before things go back to normal so
at this point this is as much a
psychological question
of what does it do to society
to be living with this for
we don't know how much longer
now that psychological pressure
has pushed some who never took it super
seriously to just say we're back to
normal either i'm vaccinated and we're
back to normal or
i'm not vaccinated and i never thought
we needed vaccines or to do anything and
i'm going to continue in that way but
when you look at the case and death
numbers tomorrow i'm going to actually
show you
cases are three times higher than a year
ago
deaths are two times higher than a year
ago that doesn't feel like it's almost
over
but at the same time you've got some
points of optimism there are some
studies that show that uh an
overwhelming majority 80 even more
percent of some some populations in some
cities have some degree of antibodies
which would be due to a combination of
infection vaccination people who never
knew they had asymptomatic cases etc so
do
what is the point of this do we really
know anything no yes maybe i don't know
we do know some things
we know that this mutates slowly enough
that when you start getting to these
higher levels of immunity
you may not do away with cases
but cases won't mean nearly as much
because it will mostly mean colds and
for the vaccinated population
that's sort of already the case i mean
when you read 1500 vaccinated people
have died it's hard to feel like that
means if you're vaccinated this no
longer matters but in the grand scheme
of the numbers that's a quite small
number
people die of the flu even when
vaccinated etc
so the last part of this is
how do we define the end are we
comfortable saying the end is
when the death numbers are the same as a
normal flu season is that the end has
this so traumatized us that even that
won't really signify the end
will it be where anyone of any age who
wants to get vaccinated can be
vaccinated which could be some time
until young kids can get vaccinated
that's another piece of this which is
how do we define the end the next thing
i want to talk about is this mu variant
mu which many of you have been emailing
me about
yesterday i mentioned that today i was
going to talk about the covet mu variant
which appears to be even more contagious
than the delta variant but i want to do
something that i don't think is being
properly done in many of the headlines
that are being written
it appears as though
mu has already lost to delta based on
the information we have and that the
peak for mu already came a month or two
ago
the headlines about mu
are the exact types of headlines you
would expect disaster worse than delta
more contagious than delta potentially
looming dystopian situation but what you
actually have to understand is that it
seems as though the peak of you mew has
passed and it's not even going to
overtake delta so let's look at a report
from the new york daily news the
headline similar to many headlines we've
seen new mu
new mu wow that's tough new mu covet
variant now found in 49 u.s states uh-oh
since being discovered in colombia the
country of colombia in january
that's nine months ago the mew variant
of covet is spread to nearly four dozen
countries and has made its presence
known in hawaii and alaska it has so far
been found in 49 states with nebraska
being the only state not to have a
detected mu variant case health
officials believe mew is even more
transmissible than delta and has the
potential to resist vaccines in the u.s
it has been in 49 states in dc
california has reported the highest
number of the latest variant with 384
167 we're in los angeles county
the identification of variants like mew
and the spreading of variants around the
globe highlights the need for la county
residents to continue to take measures
this is why getting vaccinated and
protections are so important
on august 30th the who called mew a
variant of interest due to its ability
to be more transmissible than the other
strains two cdc
i'm sorry the cdc has not yet made
similar classifications about mew fauci
says uh we are maintaining a close eye
on the mu variant despite it being not
at all even close to becoming dominant
in the u.s
but here is actually the most important
line of the article they've buried the
lead
buried buried the u.s saw its peak of mu
variant cases in mid-july
but case numbers involving that variant
have been declining since signaling
either a weakening of the strain or
indicating a worrisome future so
potentially worrisome if something even
worse is replacing it but this is a
really important detail that is not
being included in the skies falling
articles about mu
excuse me
it peaked in july and has been declining
delta continues to grow
as a percentage of all cases so when you
look at the articles more transmissible
of course is concerning
then the question is what about more
deadly and often it takes a really long
time to get information about that
you've got to track hospitalization
you've got to track death rate etc
but it appears as though we have already
passed the mu peak now why they say
worrisome is
if something even worse is ultimately
going to be what knocks out delta and
becomes dominant but i actually think
that on this issue a lot of corporate
media have been spreading a lot of what
we call fud fear uncertainty and doubt
we appear to be beyond the peak of mu
delta remains dominant
and um
if we have growing overall immunity i'm
not going to use the term herd immunity
because we seem to be still far from
that but if we continue to grow the
number of people with some level of
protection
mew to beat delta will need to find
enough people
with no protection
in order to start grabbing a bigger and
bigger foothold so of course we watch it
of course we watch it but that last line
mew appears to already have peaked in
july and is declining should really be
further up in the articles and um i know
dozens of people have been emailing me
about this and this is the the most
important piece of data we have so far
is appears to have peaked in july let me
know what you think you can find me on
twitter at d pacman we will take a break
after the break
biden's approval
continues down as we predicted what's
going on we'll talk about it in a few
moments
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25 off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
so last week we talked about president
joe biden's declining approval rating
and it's been a significant decline as
of last week joe biden's approval rating
was down about 16 percent now that's 16
percent not 16 points from about 55 to
46.
my sense last week was that joe biden's
approval rating would probably continue
down before it might recover depending
on what happens but my sense was we
hadn't yet seen the bottom the reason
that i thought that was that the full
scope of the afghanistan situation
wasn't yet in last week's polling and
what i mean by that is that the polling
we looked at early last week
was taken mostly before the suicide
attack by isis at kabul airport in
afghanistan and in fact i pointed out
last week that joe biden's approval
decline actually started in july before
any of the afghanistan situation got
going but certainly the afghanistan
situation was not helping and that we
would probably see a further decline
indeed in the last week joe biden's
approval has exactly as expected
continued to decline not dramatically
more than last week but the downward
trajectory is clear and he's now down to
just a hair over 45 approval
we care more about the average of polls
than about any individual poll we want
to look at sort of the general direction
but there are now some individual polls
showing joe biden at only 42
and 44 approval and there may be even
more of a decline so what what are the
important notes here why is this
happening what are we looking for what
do we expect
two of the major drags on joe biden's
approval right now are coveted
resurgence with delta
for which really republican governors
and anti-vas anti-vaxxers and
anti-massacres are to blame more than
joe biden's policy biden's policy has
been get people vaccinated keep schools
safe but i don't deny
that ultimately the buck stops with
biden and he has said that so that's one
drag which at a sort of nitty-gritty
level is actually the fault of mostly
republicans the second drag is
afghanistan
so if covid improves by november of 2022
for the midterms
i believe people will have forgotten
about afghanistan in general foreign
policy impacts voting less than domestic
policy and biden himself is not actually
on the ballot you can see november of 22
as a sort of referendum on joe biden for
sure but this may not really be the end
of the world for joe biden and democrats
in november of 22. now for comparison to
prior presidents joe biden's approval
today
is still seven points higher than
trump's at this point in their
presidencies
but below both where barack obama was at
this point in his presidency
and below where george w bush's approval
was at this point in his presidency
so what does it mean what's next really
there's no change from what we outlined
last week on afghanistan execution aside
joe biden got us out of a war that we
needed to get out of that's good that's
the big story the big story is
bush got us into afghanistan
um
obama didn't get us out
trump didn't get us out biden got us out
were there execution mistakes of course
and we've talked about it there's no
doubt about that
but i don't believe that the big
narrative which is biden got us out
and it didn't go perfectly is going to
impact 2022
the tough part comes where biden now
really needs a big success
but the lower his approval rating the
less likely that republicans are going
to be incentivized to work with him
unless he makes some gigantic
compromises for example
on infrastructure which might turn
biden's victory into a pyrrhic one a
pyrrhic victory one in which you sustain
so much damage in getting the victory
that in practice it's a question as to
whether really it's a victory so it's
this vicious circle
biden needs a big accomplishment to buoy
his approval rating
but having a lower lower approval rating
reduces the pressure on republicans to
actually work with joe biden because his
approval rating is already lower and the
expectations from the american public
that republicans work with him may also
be diminished joe biden is expected to
address the nation tomorrow thursday
about covid
there's a question as to whether he will
be announcing new guidelines new
restrictions mandates whatever the case
may be
we will see what kind of an audience
that gets we will see if it does
anything for his approval and i don't
know what time that is tomorrow but my
intention is to cover it live on youtube
twitch and facebook so i hope you will
join me it's been already kind of
previewed by the biden administration
that there is not going to be an
announcement of a federal vaccine
mandate tomorrow um there there was some
theorizing and theorizing is even
probably too generous the term there was
some uh speculation by some on the right
that tomorrow is the day that biden
announces a vaccine mandate and that's
it for many of them what that means i
don't know it sounds violent but okay uh
but the administration has already said
uh that is not that is not the plan in
in in so many words that this is not
their wording this is mine but it was
made clear
that joe biden is not announcing a
vaccine mandate tomorrow but he will be
announcing something and we'll see what
that does and will continue to track his
approval rating
all right i i want to talk about another
one of these horrible incidents and
listen every time we have one of these
anti-mask incidents of assault and
that's really what it is
uh i
talk about
mental illness clearly seems to be a
component with these people the woman in
this video uh which some are calling an
anti-mask karen i really am not big on
karen because it's clearly a racially
loaded term it's really applied to white
women so i stay away from it i i call
this person
a really bad person who also may be
mentally ill this is another one of
these incidents where a woman in
nebraska
some kind of covet denier some kind of
anti-massacre is repeatedly coughing
coughing coughing on the person who is
filming and we're going to look at this
and then we're going to talk about what
crimes may have been committed here so
let's start with the story this was
posted to the lincoln nebraska subreddit
um a few days ago
and the person who posted it you a user
named jessabird on
on reddit
says so my kid and i were at the store
tonight to pick up a few groceries when
this lady approached us and said
politely excuse me and to be honest i
thought she was going to ask me for help
or ask me where something was i was
about to say i don't work here lady when
she asked me why we were wearing masks
that's when i realized she wasn't
wearing one i started walking away while
replying because of the delta variant
and also because there's a mandate
then she went on about how she was born
and raised here in nebraska and it's too
bad some nebraskans have turned into
sheep she asked if i've had a vaccine
and said that my kid and i don't need to
wear masks because we look young and
healthy there were several other people
around wearing masks but for some reason
she chose to pick on me and my kid at
the end of the video some poor guy
working there tries to intervene and
basically told us all just go our
separate ways
karen walked away and i told the guy
what happened he said it wasn't the
first time he's had to deal with people
like her at work i tried to continue my
shopping but the lady followed me around
the store i told her she needs to keep
her distance and her coughing on me was
assault she kept laughing and saying
look at you it's so cute how scared you
are by this time i was absolutely livid
trying my best to hold it together in
front of my kid i didn't finish my
shopping i instead went to the self
checkout to pay for my stuff she
followed me to use the checkout right
next to me i informed the employee
manning the checkouts this woman
assaulted me by coughing deliberately
but i didn't wait around to see what the
employee would say um so let's take a
look at this video this this is
horrifying um and what's horrifying
about it is
it's less about the specific risk of
contagion
um but it's that there are people in our
country
who
would do this and who think that they
are making some kind of prescient point
by doing this all right let's take a
look let's take a listen
excuse me
i'm coming through
so this is a disgusting person
but is she also mentally ill i don't
know i don't know i mean you know normal
people don't behave this way but even
that term normal has become very loaded
in coveted times
she's coughing at me
she's coughing at me
[Music]
because i don't need to have one on i'm
not sick and neither are you okay but
you don't have to be coughing you don't
know who's sick or not
by the way how annoying are those fake
coughs
[Laughter]
oh you've got yeah and so
two years ago before anybody started
talking about covid you were okay with
daca going out not knowing you were sick
right
you don't know what to say about my
health
i don't yeah she's coughing on me i have
my allergies and she got all freaked out
because i'm talking
no she's
wear a mask okay
so
i think you get the point now there were
some people saying call the police next
time but one user on on the reddit post
about this said call the police this
time which i agree with
there's video evidence of of a crime
being committed okay what crime
we were looking into this and it seems
as though
in nebraska
this is assault in the third degree
this is nebraska of revised statute
28310
assault in the third degree a person
commits the offense of assault in the
third degree
if he intentionally knowingly or
recklessly causes bodily injury to
another person or
threatens another in a menacing manner
assault in the third degree shall be a
class one misdemeanor unless committed
in a fight or scuffle entered into by
mutual consent in which case it should
be a class two misdemeanor so that's the
most likely thing
um the other idea that's been floated is
that uh coughing coronavirus coughing
attacks
might be able to be prosecuted as
terrorism
um
and this is an article from what is the
date this is from april of 2020 when
these coughing incidents started
where nikita malik a contributor to
forbes wrote that covid19 is considered
a biological agent
meaning that if you deliberately cough
on a policeman or merchandise which was
what was going on at the time
you could be charged with terrorism um i
think you know it's probably a stretch
to get a a conviction on that but at
least there's the idea that it could be
we do need to throw the book at these
people this is not you know when we talk
about
anti-social
behavior
detrimental to all of society
where culturally
[Music]
from a health standpoint from any aspect
you want to look at this
not taking seriously people who go out
and to make some kind of political point
i don't even know what it is or because
they're just out of their minds or a
combination of the two
are coughing during a pandemic on people
to scare them right
it's got to be taken as seriously as the
law allows so i am all for
if you if if you can do a terrorism
charge do it if this is assault in the
third degree under nebraska law
go with it but
the people have to call the police and i
understand that this woman wrote i just
wanted to get out of there i'm not
blaming her for that but let's all come
together and say that if we see this
stuff let's make every effort to
actually get police involved and really
make sure that these people even if they
don't get convicted have to spend months
dealing with the justice system because
of the disgusting thing that they did
we'll have more more on this particular
incident
um on the show instagram you can find us
on instagram
davidpakmanshow find me on instagram
david.pakman we'll take a quick break
and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
sergey young who is the founder of the
longevity vision fund and also author of
the new book the science and technology
of growing young sergey it's so great to
have you on today
hi david thanks for having me today my
pleasure
so
let's just jump right in um i've
recently been reading uh in addition to
your book the book scale by jeffrey west
and one of the things that jeffrey west
talks about is that when it comes to
human aging when you look
mathematically at metabolic rate and a
few other sort of basic factors it seems
as though
the top-end kind of natural lifespan if
you avoid car accidents and infectious
disease and you know the best scenario
is about 120 years of age now one of the
things i find really interesting about
your book is you start to talk about
this in steps you talk about living to
150. you talk about that so you're not
just jumping in and saying as some do
a thousand years of life span is very
very soon on the horizon you're talking
about incremental so talk to us about
that i mean how how do we go from this
natural limit of 100 to 120 up to 150
perfect great question so
well let's let's start from today what
are the options that we have today to
extend our lifespan so frankly speaking
all of them you know people call them
boring or my mom told me that so it's
lifestyle changes it's early diagnostic
using power of wearables technologies
this will help us to live 200
healthy and happy ears so that's that's
what we can do today from today's
like a stage of development of
technology and science this is actually
pretty important because
we have something exciting in the field
of longevity science and technology
coming to all of us in the next 10 to 20
years within what i call in the book
near horizon of longevity innovation but
it's very important to stay on longevity
breach and be as healthy and happy as
possible so then in 10 20 years time our
body and mind is worth extending its
resource so that's one
and it's like a separate part of the
book it's a bonus chapter is as
as
as
twice as long as any other chapter
there's so many things you can do today
i call it 10 longevity choices
so then the second piece uh
is a near horizon of longevity
innovation and again this is
technologies and scientific
breakthroughs which will be available to
all of us in the next 10 15 20 years
and when people ask me what are the most
exciting uh from this list i'm always
talking about gene editing in gene
therapy
organ regeneration our ability to regrow
and replace organs inside our body
similar to what we do with the old car
extending its resource and longevity and
appeal in the next 10 years we'll have
a completely new class of drugs which
will focus on aging in its core rather
than any particular disease this is the
kind of drugs that we have today so
that's again near horizon of longevity
and then
there's something more on the horizon
it's called far horizon of longevity
innovation and i'm talking about
technologies which will be available to
us in the next 25 to 50 years from now
and this is when man and machine will
become one when we talk about
integration between computer power and
and human intellect and um
without changing the definition of human
it's going to be very difficult to live
beyond 120 or 150 years so okay let's
let's stop there for a second because
that's really important
so
you you seem to be acknowledging that
there is this sort of
metabolic and cellular natural ceiling
to human longevity
that
is going to need some more major change
or intervention in order to be extended
significantly
yes so
what we can do within the current
biological view on the human body
biological perspective has a limit
whether it's 100 or 120 or 130 years i
don't know but it's obviously in this
field so then
we need we would need to complement the
biological perspective and engineering
or technological perspective and look at
the integration of this for us to be
able to live longer but the bigger
question is not the science and not in
technology the biggest question is
ethics and regulation because we have
created technology to extend our lives
david but we haven't created life that
we want to extend 60 to 80 percent of
people in the world depending on the
country would say no to life extension
opportunities so we will need to sort
out a lot of ethical issues and almost
create a new amazing version of this
world and society for us to embrace the
idea of longer living i call it morality
of immortality and this is my biggest
worry this is my biggest concern this is
where we need to have a conversation
about ethical choices before we embrace
the technology yeah well you know i've
interviewed uh longevity researcher
aubry de gray several times over the
last 15 or so years
and he often makes news for the things
that are more
salacious that he says like the first
person to live to a thousand has already
been born or something like that and you
know
maybe that's true maybe it's not but
that what i find more interesting about
what he says are when i bring up the
ethical considerations how triage
considerations change if the upper limit
of life is extended or what is the
economic impact what is the
environmental impact of people living so
much longer he says it sort of will
mostly work itself out like if people
live a lot longer
the birth rate will go down for example
what do you think about that
so i i do believe that there's so many
things that we need to change
in this world for us to be able to enjoy
this far horizon of longevity so a few
of them like
i i do believe longevity and longevity
technology has an opportunity to become
a unifying theme for the nation and for
society because
someone need to close an equality gap
which is widening all the time so i my
mission is to bring affordable and
accessible version of digital healthcare
and technology to the world i'm not
interested to create something for the
rich ones right so that's that's one
second is
this whole relationship with mother
nature as you pointed out
when you live 75 years there's there's
always a temptation to say okay i'm
gonna die in 20 years from now next
generations will sort it out for
themselves if you're going to live
huntington 20 150 years i do believe
that it gives us an opportunity to be
much more responsible in our
relationship with uh with the planet
with the modern
we're going to face the consequences of
our own actions
or the other thing is and it's probably
the final comment on the ethical side is
um
social constructs you know these binary
social constructs that we have today
like career uh
marriage um retirement
they've been developed in a society
where the average lifespan was 35 years
like two-thirds of the marriages are
going through divorce in the first five
years
of their life
and this is not great and we would need
to come up with a variety of the options
for
you know two people in this world to be
you know to fix their responsibility for
like kids growing
uh or anything else or this whole
career thing a retirement thing it's
also binary it's just you work full-time
and then you like full-time retire and
two most dangerous years of your life is
the year of your birth because we still
have this high infant mortality and year
of your retirement because you lose in
in today's binary framework full-time
work full-time retirement people lose
the opportunity for social realization
and this is one of those
most important component of you your
desire willingness and ability to live
longer so we just need to rethink can i
have as many careers as decades in my
life
i need to have an answer to this
question and our society needs to be
ready and and change itself and its norm
to accommodate this yeah that's a very
interesting social question about
increased lifespans that i've read about
which is maybe both from the standpoint
of career and even for some people from
the standpoint of relationship there
would be
more more chapters or you would plan on
more chapters maybe that than people
plan on now let me ask about a couple of
other kind of finer point things
in the longevity circles there's a lot
of talk about the possibility of drugs
specific medications
providing uh additional life span often
the diabetes medication metformin is
mentioned
what is the what is the the real data on
metformin as a longevity drug
so um
the whole issue is that aging is not
considered as disease today so there is
no regulatory framework for someone to
launch metformin study
which would test
particular outcome of taking midform in
a regular basis for your longevity and
this is where we are today i do think
that you know all of us will have an
opportunity to invest more time and
resources into
you know improving our health span and
lifespan when regulatory change will
will happen having said that um
there are so many cases in in medicine
in the history of medicine where
something has been discovered as a side
effect
and apparently this is what happened
with metformin so it's clear that for
certain portion of population certain
age and and relation to diabetes
metformin adds two three four years uh
to the life span and health span
well the question is whether it works
only for people who are in a particular
risk
group
like suffering from diabetes or it works
for the general population and this is
still the question that we need to
resolve so that's why i'm on the board
of american federation of aging research
and we working on the trial it's a huge
trial to be launched hopefully next year
in the u.s
under fda
approval and guidance where 3 000 people
will be taken metformin and we'll have
more data in three five years from now
whether we have a new class of drugs
which
which is looking at and focusing at
aging and its core
or
metformin is a great diabetes drug but
unfortunately it doesn't really have any
you know particular positive lifespan
extension effect on the other parts of
population so it's very promising but as
everything in medicine we well let's
just test this before we embrace the
idea of of looking on the forum so
that's why you know everything i talk
about in the near horizon of longevity 5
10 15 years from now i'm always saying
guys be conservative unless you've been
advised by your doctor to take it and it
says you have a critical condition well
let's just wait stay on longevity breach
for five ten years and so then we can
embr embrace and and use these
technologies and this scientific
discoveries in much more responsible and
less risky way yeah that seems eminently
reasonable uh and if people google
metformin longevity they will find a lot
of hyperbole that does not yet match as
you're pointing out the data very
important um life expectancy over the
last few years
is actually down slightly in the united
states and of course we're in a pandemic
that has on average slightly reduced
life expectancy we have big disparity
based on economic situation in the
united states
when you're looking longer term at
longevity what do you make of this
short-term reduction in life expectancy
so it's clearly a u.s problem
we i haven't seen any other developed
nation on this planet which would show
this um
very difficult and i say it with a lot
of love right uh
this
uh tragic situation with life expectancy
i mean it's smaller number it's decrease
of 0.2 years right every year and it's
happened in the in the last three years
out of five pre-pandemic
so the reasons being
is
is something needs to change in in the
healthcare sector in the u.s u.s has the
most expensive
18 of gdp and the most inefficient
healthcare system in the world
uk united kingdom um spends eight
percent of its gdp on healthcare and has
much better results like singapore spend
five percent of their uh budget gdp on
healthcare and uh they're on number one
or number two place in the world health
span wise and lifespan wise together
with japan so something needs to change
and and obviously this huge impact of
opioid crisis
to this number so if we will localize
this problem it's going to be better but
obviously there are a number of
fundamental problems like with obesity
with the diet of americans with um
you know
high degree and and and and intensity of
antibiotics in the in the meat and fish
etc so uh having said that there's a
light in the end of the tunnel because
the medicine of the future it's going to
be much more technology driven and uh
based on data so that's why i'm bracing
you know a lot of wearables which are
coming to our life wearables is not a
convenience device for you anymore and
it doesn't matter whether it's feedback
watch or oring does not matter it's
going to be our personalized healthcare
device and the change in healthcare will
come from new players doing completely
new things this is where i see the
solution to the car and
in in the medicine well two of the
really two of the things you talk about
that i love because so many
longevity investors
really don't talk about it are number
one
we we have to make life such that people
want to extend it number one that's very
very important i'm glad you mentioned
that and then number two
there are economic questions about
access and you seem to be addressing
both in the book which i think is great
thank you david yeah it's very important
like in the u.s you know two zip codes
next to each other had 15 years
of difference in their lifespan i i
couldn't find even you know logical or
rational explanation behind that you
know a part of inequality
uh gap that we have in this world i mean
it's and the u.s is not an exception
like in london uh you know this same
situation will give you in some of the
cases 17.7 years difference well that's
why i'm embracing technology we're
investing in technology to democratize
access to healthcare like decreasing the
cost of cancer diagnostic by two uh five
ten times decreasing the cost of
ultrasound diagnostic by 10 times and
this is real numbers from these startups
that we funded uh or decreasing the cost
of um
organ transplantation like clearer
transportation by 10 times so i'm very
hopeful that
this will give us an opportunity for all
of us to be as brave as
thinking of healthcare as a basic good
and basic service which would need to be
provided to everyone for free of charge
this is my dream
the book is the science and technology
of growing young we've been speaking
with the book's author sergey young
sergey so great having you on i really
appreciate it
thank you david stay healthy and happy
please
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right let's get to a
few more things um it's been a very very
strange 24 hours for the former
president donald trump while joe biden
prepares to address the nation tomorrow
about coronavirus and to lay out
a six-pronged strategy for how we are
going to get beyond this thing donald
trump is going to be doing pay-per-view
commentary of some kind for a boxing
match former president donald trump and
also appeared on newsmax last night and
lied completely uncontrollably just
totally uncontrollably about um
everything i want to start with this
first clip donald trump was asked about
the california gubernatorial election
which we will be talking about in in the
next segment we are going to be covering
the results live
next week this is an important situation
in california donald trump claimed of
course without any evidence
that it's probably rigged this is
happening in the context of gavin newsom
starting to pull away in terms of people
saying we want to keep newsom instead of
recall him in the polling
we'll get to that polling in a moment
here is donald trump just spreading lies
it wasn't a joke when we said they will
just start claiming any election they
lose was rigged that's exactly what
donald trump is doing here take a look
at this got the recall election coming
up in less than a week it's actually
happening as we speak the polls appear
to show newsome look safer at this point
larry elder is the man that could take
it from him what do you think happens in
california
well it's probably rigged they're
sending out all ballots it's all uh the
the ballots are you know mail out
mail-in ballots in fact i guess you even
have a case where you can make your own
ballot when that happens uh
nobody's gonna win except uh these
democrats so you know look they're very
good the one thing they're good at is
rigging elections so i predict it's a
rigged election let's see how it
so what's going on in reality
is simply that gavin newsom is pulling
away it was very very close about a
month ago in early august uh basically
split awareness was much lower about the
fact that this was going on at the time
among californians and as we and others
i mean i'm not i'm not saying we
accomplished anything but just as
there's been more and more attention by
media about the fact that hey
you could see newsome removed despite
the amazing economy in california and
replaced with a lunatic like larry elder
you've started to see the keep newsom
crowd
uh pull away where now they are almost
plus 10 plus 10. now everybody's got a
vote in california my brother said he uh
was was filling out his ballot today
it's got to be post postmarked by uh
actually i hope that it's i hope i'm
right about i think it has to be
postmarked by tuesday
um so hopefully that'll happen but there
is no evidence whatsoever that this is
rigged it wasn't a joke when we said
this is the new story
anytime they lose they'll say it was
rigged mitt romney who won in utah
remember that confrontation i believe it
was at
national airport in washington d.c
where a woman came up to him and said
you didn't really win that your win was
also rigged any win they don't like they
simply say was rigged and what's going
on unfortunately
is that this is the type of stuff that
could lead to what we're worried will
happen on september 18th which is
another one of these
um
riots i mean i i hope it doesn't go that
way trump continuing to lie throughout
the interview then he repeated his often
cited uh lie that he was down there at
ground zero on 9 11 we're coming up on
the 20th anniversary of 9 11 and here's
donald trump revisiting that same lie at
that time you you offered to help um
okay and what a mess we had in new york
city give us a reflection of that period
of time 20 years later imagine by the
way asking trump to reflect that's
that's that's that alone is funny well i
was down there
right after the event and i brought a
big crew of people down
and uh i helped a lot of other people
help those first responders are very
brave and i'm telling you that's a lie
trump has been telling that lie a really
really long time back in 2019 you might
remember trump commemorated
911 first responders by making it all
about himself
he has told this lie many many times
here is trump in 2019 telling something
very similar untrue it also provides
pensions for those who are suffering
from cancer and other illnesses stemming
from the toxic debris
they were exposed to in the aftermath of
the attacks many of those affected were
firefighters police officers and other
first responders and i was down there
also
but i'm not considering myself a first
responder but i was down there i spent a
lot of time down there with you so there
there appears to be absolutely no
evidence of that snopes looked into it
and um
he uh claimed that he was there
uh doing who knows what but snopes spoke
to officials from new york city fire
department they spoke to
the construction demolition people who
were at ground zero for days and days
and days after the 9 11 attacks nobody
recalls ever seeing trump down there and
trump has been exaggerating um about it
for a very very long time so that's
what's going on and then even weirder as
if it needs to get any weirder
donald trump is going to be providing
boxing commentary
for
uh trillers of vander holyfield veder
belfort fight
on the 20th anniversary of 9 11 just
like everything is so bizarre it's weird
enough
that trump as a former president is
doing boxing commentary
it's kind of even weirder in some
strange way that he's doing it on the
20th anniversary of 9 11
just all of it reeks of bizarre
confusion and i don't ultimately know
what trump's political future is but so
far it's all looking very strange let's
now talk a little bit about
the man
who
is the most likely
to replace gavin newsom in california
if the vote to recall him uh decides to
remove him so remember it's sort of like
a two-part vote in next week's
california gubernatorial recall the
first thing is do you want to remove
gavin newsom if the answer is no that's
it it's over museum stays and let's hope
that takes place
if the answer is yes then there is a
sort of subsequent ballot
um where the question is well who do you
want to replace gavin newsom with the
guy who's leading is a black
conservative named larry elder who has a
long history of disgusting comments
about abortion
about gay rights about so many different
things
he appeared on i guess this is uh yeah
this is the candace owens show which i
guess is part of prageru
dennis prager part of prageru
um and larry elder the guy who if it's
not going to be gavin newsom has the
best shot at being the next governor of
california said you can make the case
that slave owners should have gotten
reparations when slavery ended let's
take a listen to this together right
behind that by the way when you
mentioned that the uk was ahead of us
they were do you know that the slave
owners were compensated
after they lost their quote unquote
property the government compensated
slave owners i didn't know that yeah and
so when people talk about rep
reparations yeah it's fascinating
candace is really learning a lot here
huh do they really want to have that
conversation because like it or not
slavery was legal
and so their property their legal
property was taken away from them after
the after the civil war so uh you could
make an argument that the people that
are old reparations and not only just
black people but also the people whose
quote property close quote was taken
away after after the end of the civil
war isn't that just amazing guys
now he says you can make the argument
there's lots of arguments that can be
made but shouldn't be made
it's sort of like
we're just asking questions where yeah
it's an innocuous enough phrase but
sometimes the questions you're asking uh
and and the and the questions you're not
asking and the answers that you're
presenting it's all very toxic and
manipulative now by the way
uh slave owners got reparations after
the civil war it's not just that what
larry elder is saying is vile it's not
just that
there could be nothing more retrograde
than electing as governor of california
of any state but of california uh
because that's where we're actually
looking at a recall here
it would be crazy to put a guy who talks
about reparations for slave owners in
the governor's mansion in california
slave owners got reparations after the
civil war on april 16th of 1862
president abraham lincoln signed the
district of columbia compensated
emancipation act the law prohibited
slavery in the district and it forced
its 900 odd slave holders to free their
slaves and the government paid the slave
owners about 300 per slave that's like 8
grand in in modern money inflation
adjusted now that wasn't in every
state but we've seen reparations for the
slave owners
and it's all pretty damn crazy now
during this same interview i want to
look at one more clip of this larry
elder also added
black people get longer sentences
but for legitimate reasons he he likes
the fact that there is a sentencing
disparity for the same crimes along
racial lines quite a guy huh
he hired eric holder his ag who once
said when it comes to matters of race
america has been a nation of cowards
and eric holder has called voter id an
example of pernicious racism right he's
called the fact that blacks get longer
sentences uh and they do so for
legitimate reasons that judges taking
consideration your entire criminal
history he called that example
pernicious racism right he called the
fact that black boys get kicked out more
often than white boys do in schools an
example of pernicious racism never mind
their behavior this guy has been a more
dangerous race card hustler in my
opinion than even jesse jackson and now
sherman
suit and tie
speaks and speaks calmly and people have
much more
um so there it is guys um it is
black conservative quote conservative
candace owns
learning from black republican larry
elder
about why it makes sense that black boys
would get harsher sentences for the same
crimes than white boys this is
the leading alternative
to governor gavin newsom to become the
governor of california so just a
reminder
fortunately
gavin newsom has been pulling away
now leading uh keep gavin leading by
almost 10 points over remove gavin but
everybody in california must vote we're
going to have live coverage of results
to the extent that we get them on the
same day
um next tuesday and i hope you will join
me for that we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p 2192 david
p
here is a voicemail from a medical
student
explaining where some of the riffraff
around ivermectin is coming from let's
take a listen to this
hey dave i'm a vet student in arizona
and i just wanted to call and say that i
really love your
segment on hypervectin today and i also
wanted to say that i think diver mexico
thing is a little bit more complicated
than people are letting on um
obviously ivermectin does not work in
humans for covid but a lot of the people
just think that it does they're citing a
study that looked at iberonectin
uh in an in-vitro way so they just took
cells in the petri dish and injected
them with ivermectin and right lo and
behold they killed coven but
uh the dosage that is required to do
that is so incredibly high that uh in
any person that tried to attain that
level of hybrid mechanism in their blood
they would
probably die or have severe side effects
so that's why
it doesn't work
so
i think that it's just sad that no one
actually realizes that so
a great segment really appreciate it
everyone yeah i appreciate the
additional information you know this is
one of those things where like
if iver mekden really worked i would be
saying this is fantastic guy like i
don't i don't care you know before the
entire hydroxychloroquine fiasco
exploded
about 10 days before trump came out and
talked about hydroxy
uh i
did a segment where i said here are six
things we are looking at that are being
studied
which might have an effect on covid
and i listed hydroxychloroquine like i i
never had a problem i don't know anyone
on the left who really has a problem and
there's this conspiracy thing about the
reason that they're covering up that
these things work is if there's a good
treatment for covid then the vaccine
wouldn't qualify for emergency use
authorization
there's no evidence whatsoever that
that's going on
if iver mektin had
an efficacy signal in a
you know a blinded
with a placebo group
randomized controlled trial i would say
we should be looking at using that or
hydroxychloroquine or whatever
but it's just not the case and we can't
pretend that things are something that
they are not we've got a great bonus
show for you today unemployment benefits
end today for millions of americans
we're going to talk about it flu season
is coming and it could be a pretty bad
flu season i got my flu vaccine a couple
weeks ago i will tell you how it went
um and there are new plans for a 400
billion dollar city in the desert which
have been unveiled very interesting and
we will talk about it all on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpacman.com
and i will speak to you then in mere
moments
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman